okay let's try the four three four area
code caller from four three four go
ahead you hear me yeah just speak up and
we can hear you okay you know how
speaker school I was calling about an
old video that I watched a while ago
it's not recent between you and Kyle
kolinsky mm-hmm okay so you guys were
basically trying to refute the one
article that I believe said that the
last dog that the right actually
dominates you - right and Kyle disagree
with that and I I'm not sure I believe
you did as well but yeah I was going to
say that uh I think the right does
dominate YouTube I'm gonna be honest
because the amount of subscribers that
say steven crowder has and the amount of
views that he has if you go to his
channel he's got like half a billion
views now that's just steven crowder i
think that's more than you have I think
that's more than Kyle kolinsky has well
we've got I mean I think what I think I
think we've got close to half a billion
three hundred and fifty million with 300
yeah you see I'm not saying that I you
know I'm a big fan of your show
no I get it I get it you're saying that
youyou said you honestly feel as though
the right does dominate YouTube I mean I
think yeah to retake that assessment
you'd have to have more than just like
how many views this crowder have versus
me right we'd need to have some it we
need to systematize the question and
we'd need to say we are going to look at
total subscribers and total views for
channels starting at set okay it sounds
like you have more you want to say more
point I haven't have been responded but
it sounds like you're on to the next
point right no no no no no I I just
wanted to elaborate just just a bit more
because what you said is true like I did
bring up Crowder but like the larger
point I was gonna make was if you go
when you look at Crowder or you look at
Shapiro yeah you look at say male
innopolis like these guys are huge like
the following that these guys have is
massive hmm and the the left doesn't
seem to have any sort of uh following or
at least not a follow
that is as long as there is it don't
think that's the exact same
enlightenment yet hold on a second let
me see if we can talk through this
because I this is interesting okay you
you interrupted my response to your
first point to say that here's the
really what you want to say and then you
just said the exact same thing and still
didn't you cited even less data I mean I
I'm just trying to say that I don't see
how the left-wing counterparts to
Crowder's are even half the elected
channels on half the size you don't have
half the views it's just what about the
young journalist point to make what
about the Young Turk so they're way
bigger than credit right like orders of
magnitude bigger than crowder where do
they figure it well I mean that's that's
a decent point I just I just feel like
overall I feel like but the thing is
you're not making a point overall that's
here so this is a good lesson in
thinking critically I'm trying to talk
with you about overall right because
Kyle and I in that video clip we said
big picture how do we assess the
strength of the left versus the strength
of the right on youtube you called me
and you first said steven crowder steven
Crowder's channel is bigger than yours
and I said okay short but what we need
to do when you interrupted me I was
trying to explain to you that we would
need to establish some kind of system to
say how are we gonna measure overall and
then I gave you an anecdotal
counterpoint which was the Young Turks
and then you switched from saying look
at steven crowder to saying okay yeah
but we need to look at it overall that's
what I'm telling you we need to look at
it overall how would we do that
no I I do appreciate the consistent yeah
you do make a good point good all right
very good listen I appreciate the call
we will look into measuring the size of
the left and right on YouTube I mean I
think it would be an interesting thing
right let's figure out do we say let's
look at channels 10,000 subscribers and
larger that publish in news and politics
at least you know on that they're active
channels and then let's add up the total
number of subscribers will rank them as
left right or sort of non-political and
see where it shakes out there's we could
do that I think it would be an
interesting exercise and we could figure
that out
once and for all let's take a quick
break don't hang up if you're holding
because we're gonna do another round of
phone calls after the break don't hang
up quick break more calls after this